i have said for a long time on this show
that the left
through political correctness or
wokeness or cancer culture or whatever
is seeking purely to destroy to
dismantle to deconstruct this is not a
positive movement
trying to build something it's just
trying to tear stuff down
and sometimes left-wingers say michael
that's not fair no
you're straw manning that's not true
well one social justice warrior with a
podcast
kim brown her show is called burn it
down with kim brown i think you can get
the thesis of what that is
she is acknowledging that what we're
seeing right now in leftist activism
is purely designed to destroy
i support all that i support them
looting
the the damn dollar tree i support the
looting of
uh what other [ __ ] do they loot uh like
the like the advanced auto parts
um i remember last year they looted
target i support all that
loot all that [ __ ] do you know why
because black people and
marginalized and oppressed people could
loot every store
in this whole country for 200 years it
would not even come close
to the debt that america owes us
but of course that's not true america
doesn't owe any people or any people's
anything nothing nunc niente nada
this is true of the west more broadly
the west though
though the west flagellates itself and
says oh i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
the west does not owe anybody anything
the west produced
the greatest civilization in the history
of the world which has been
an un fathomable blessing
to the entire globe unfortunately the
opinion that america and the west
owe something to everybody else has
gained a lot of currency on the left it
has come
to dominate our national conversation
we're only focusing
on these screaming radical leftists i
hate to be a kicker
i always long for peace but the wheel
that squeaks the loudest is the one
that gets the grease i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from josh pedrazza
pedraza i don't know something like that
i'm trying to make it really italian
he says if fouchy came down to florida
and saw the open bars
he would probably tear his cloak and
yell blasphemy
blasphemy he is the caiaphas of our
present religious order the high priest
of secular progressivism i can't believe
that people can't see it maybe they
can't see it because they don't have
great glasses if you want great glasses
go check out coastal at coastal.com you
can get prescription glasses starting at
nine dollars with free shipping and
60-day risk-free returns plus
they have the most advanced virtual try
on technology that you will find
anywhere turn your frames into
sunglasses by testing out colored lens
tints
or finally see what a cat eye or aviator
would really look like on your face
right on your phone because sometimes
people get a little a little ambitious
with their glasses you want to see what
it really looks like
i've never seen try on technology the
sort that you get at coastal it's so if
it you move your head around you can see
how it looks on the side it's really
really terrific and the prices cannot be
beat
great selection for a limited time
they're offering our listeners the best
deal that they have going anywhere
30 off your first pair of glasses at
coastal.com
michael get free shipping 60 day free
risk free returns
and 30 off at coastal.com michael
discount applied at checkout this is
only for a limited time so head on over
there right now
c-o-a-s-t-a-l dot com slash michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l some restrictions
apply everybody is apologizing for
things
that they don't need to apologize for
because of the
imagined transgressions of the west i'm
not even talking about
real transgressions with every every
civilization has i'm talking about the
imagined transgressions
hank azaria who is the voice actor from
the simpsons he's the guy
who does apoo if you haven't listened to
the simpsons apu is a guy who kind of
talks like a stereotypical indian guy
apu is now this is very racist
if an indian or pakistani guy voices up
who does the exact same voice that
totally fine if a white guy like hank
azaria does apoo
this very racist terrible azaria just
apologized for the seven millionth time
he said what i really do apologize
it's important i apologize for my part
in creating that and participating in
that
part of me feels like i need to go to
every single indian person in this
country
and personally apologize and sometimes
i do that is very pathetic that's sad
that is neurotic you should seek
professional help hanka's area but it's
also
empty because hank's area has made a lot
of money on the symptoms
simpsons rather last i checked he hasn't
been
doling out 100 bills to every indian guy
that he meets on the street he hasn't
been
donating giving away all of his money he
still enjoys the fruits of the simpsons
he just
feels bad about it just like so many
masochistic people in the west
of all races but especially the white
liberals enjoy the fruits of the west
they still enjoy this nice civilization
they just want to denigrate it they want
to deride it they want to apologize for
it
all the time indian people
are not offended by apu i'm speaking
only anecdotally here
i have many indian friends they are not
they don't think that apu should be
cancelled
okay i don't think that uh mario and
luigi should be cancelled
as a member of the italian race or at
least partially the italian race
i don't think so people who have it
really
really well they got it real good they
need to invent things to complain about
if they are in this kind of perverse
society where
whereby er in which rather
complaints and grievance has social
currency there was an
article in the l.a times some commentary
the casual racism of mispronouncing an
asian person's
name they're really upset i actually
followed this story a little bit because
some of
some of my friends in the theater
community in la la theater's
theater community has this ovation
awards ceremony it's a smaller awards
show for
for plays in the la area and the
organizers
mispronounced the name of an
asian-american nominee
and they displayed the wrong photo of
one of the actors
you see the name i forget the name is
spelled j-u-l-l-y
i believe and they pronounced it jelly
or something but it's really pronounced
julie and
that's this is a big problem
every single time that i go to a coffee
shop in this country
and i order a coffee and they say what's
your name and i say michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l that's how you spell
michael it's one of the most popular
names in the world
when i get my coffee they spell it
m-i-c-h-e-a-l where is my reparations
where is my apology how can i even get
out of bed in the morning i'm so
offended
no it's not a big deal it just doesn't
matter it's fine
j-u-l-l-y is an uncommon name
in this country it is no surprise that
somebody might
mispronounce it furthermore
there is something positively good
about mispronouncing foreign names in
this country
i have many ancestors who had foreign
names when they got to this country
i am glad that this country
mispronounced those names
my grandfather's last name
is misspelt because when they went to
ellis island
the guy at ellis island didn't take the
time he didn't really know what how do
you spell it how many n's how many s's
what okay well whatever here's here's
your new last name
i like that because america
has a culture and when we take people
into this culture
they need to give up maybe not their
whole culture but they need to give up
part of it and they need to get on board
with this culture
and they need to learn this language and
they need to renounce to some degree
the land they've left if they really
want to be part of this country
that's a good thing i'm glad it's
wonderful to
speak other languages i speak other
languages it's wonderful to
engage with other cultures i love doing
that all the time
but we cannot expect the united states
and the west more broadly uniquely
to give away its identity
and uniquely to apologize for sins that
are ubiquitous around the world and that
frankly other civilizations
have committed to a far greater extent
you see this notably with slavery the
the
liberals pretend that the west invented
slavery or uniquely practiced slavery
of course that isn't true slavery
existed long before it
came to the west and it existed long
after
it left the west and it existed and
continues to exist even more viciously
than it was practiced in many parts of
the west what's unique about the west
is that we got rid of it in parts of
africa and parts of asia it continues to
be practiced
today it's good to apologize
when you do something wrong and it's
good to forgive people when
they do something wrong to you that is
according to the late
conservative philosopher roger scrutin
that is essential to civilization
so i like that i wish we lived in a
culture right now where i where i could
apologize if i do something wrong and
you know you would forgive me and that'd
be fine
when you apologize you sacrifice your
pride when you forgive someone you
sacrifice your resentment you both
sacrifice something that means something
to you
and you move along together in society
we don't live in that culture right now
it is not in good faith
you heard it from that crazy leftist at
the top of the show who i think
represents a lot of people
when she said no we want to burn it down
it's good to loot it's good
to burn down stores that's not a fringe
opinion
kamala harris bailed the people who
actually burned down those stores out of
jail she's the sitting vice president
in that culture that does not
agree that we should all continue to get
along together then you can't
simply you know we'll just forgive a
little bit we'll
move on we'll sacrifice our resentment
no way
our society seems incapable of that
right now it's it's really nice
to have an open broad private sphere
this is this kind of the
republican politics of the last 20 years
we made this neat distinction between
the private sector and the public sector
right the public sector that's the
government
government bad and the private sector
that's business small business big
business that's
good and whatever business does that's
good and whatever government does that's
bad
well what happens when the businesses
start going just as woke maybe more woke
than the government
what happens when those private
allegedly private businesses
start controlling the flow of
information around our
public sphere what happens when those
businesses start undermining our
elections
what happens when we're not all just
trying to get along together to build
something
but actually even corporate america has
been
hijacked is just rolled over
into helping the radicals burn down our
society
are we going to throw up our hands and
because of some
shallow pseudo-conservative principles
say well you know if the government
wants to destroy our society and our
election system we should just let that
happen
that's a good thing that's conservative
nothing more conservative than
supporting terrorists who go around the
country burning down
our buildings and undermining our
elections no i don't think so
you have to push back
you have to recognize that this fringe
thing that we used to say oh it's just
on the campuses
wait until those radical snowflakes get
into the real world well guess what the
real world is now
acquiescing to them you have to stand up
for a separate
set of standards which is the point i
explain in great detail in my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order
you can go get that wherever you
pre-order your books and you can also
pre-order
an autographed first edition well some
prominent republicans are really wising
up to this they are really leading the
charge
they're being called heretics liberals
by the squishes but actually they are
asserting a very conservative principle
those guys including ted cruz mike lee
and josh
hawley they know what time it is if you
want to know what time it is you got to
go get a movement watch
in a tiny apartment in southern
california two college dropouts teamed
up to create a watch company that broke
all the rules
movement grew into one of the fastest
growing watch brands shipping to over
160 countries
across the globe now movement has
expanded into blue light glasses that
protect your eyes from your screens
minimalist jewelry and more style
essentials that will not break the bank
all out of their california headquarters
movement watches have the look
and quality of watches that you would
see in a department store 400 bucks 500
bucks
but they cost a fraction of that price
because they were built online they own
their process from start to finish they
will ship
directly to you you get a beautiful
watch shipped right to your door for
free
and if you don't love it you can ship it
right back for free
they have a ton of really cool styles
i've i've worn
i think three different movement watches
over the years and i can't even tell
which one's my favorite because they
have an automatic watch wow that's
pretty cool
but they've got some of the quartz
watches are really excellent styling
it's kind of retro but also has that
modern minimalist thing if you want to
elevate your look with style that does
not break the bank
then join the movement get 15 off today
with free shipping and free returns go
to mvmt.com
knowles that is mvmt.com knowles
senator ted cruz i don't just say it
because we host a show together
i don't just say it because he's a
friend of mine that guy
sees where the republican party needs to
go
he does and he's not alone
with him mike lee with him
josh hawley so that by the way this is
not just a
a matter of a libertarian side or a
more traditional conservative side i
mean look at those two guys mike lee
much more libertarian
josh hawley much more of a traditional
conservative
and senator cruz seems to be leading the
pack here
in particular in his attacks on the woke
corporations
he's recognizing this isn't about one
faction of the republican party or
another faction
this is about just seeing that we apply
eternal principles to changing
circumstances and the circumstances as
such right now
that we cannot let these corporations
get away with it specifically major
league baseball
listen to senator cruz this last month
is seeing a significant and indeed a
dramatic change in our country and not a
change for the good
this past month we have seen the rise
of the woke corporation we have seen the
rise of big business
enforcing a woke
standard it's always been the case that
big
business wants to get in bed with big
government it's always been the case
that big business seeks handouts seeks
subsidies
seeks special benefits at the expense of
the little guy at the expense
of the small business but in the past
month
these woke corporations have decided to
become the political enforcer
for democrats in washington they've made
the decision
to get in bed even at the price of
spreading disinformation
bingo there it is you hear that key word
there standard
enforcer the woke corporations are
pushing
a radical standard on this country that
is
undermining our country specifically in
the case of the mlb in georgia they are
trying to undermine
election laws and the ability of the
people of georgia through their
representatives
to protect the ballot box all at the
behest of democrats
who want to undermine our election
system cruz totally right
josh hawley gets it too so it's time for
a new round of trust busting
in the united states major league
baseball is a great place to start this
is why i support senator lee's
legislation proud to join him and
senator cruz on it
it's time that we sent a clear signal
that first of all there shouldn't be
these dramatic carve-outs
in our anti-trust laws like the one the
supreme court made up
for major league baseball and it's also
time that we sent the signal
that no corporation is above the law
that no corporation should be able to be
a power in a state
unto itself whether we're talking about
major league baseball or whether we're
talking about big tech
or big pharma or big banks all of these
corporations
exist to serve our democracy the people
of the united states and ultimately
competition
free open competition is the guarantor
of liberty it's what protects the
people's liberty is what protects our
democratic process
and we've got to we've got to act now to
ensure that there is that free
robust competition again in all sectors
of our economy
and major league baseball is a great
place to start i'm delighted to join
this legislation
big government is not the only problem
big tech is a problem
big corporate america is a problem big
big
big unlimited power in the hands of a
few is
is the problem that is the progressive
dream that's what woodrow wilson writes
about explicitly
when he says what is progress progress
is taking taking our old system which
was under the laws of newton where we
have eternal laws
governing an eternal nature where we
need checks and balances we're going to
junk all of that because now we need an
energetic organism of government
that is living under the laws of of
charles darwin
and we need to
ditch the old constitutional order and
rev up so that we can move forward
into progress no no we don't there are
there remain eternal laws so this
remains
a fallen world and we need checks and
balances i mean even if you think of
the the divine right of kings the claim
of the divine right of kings
even that involves a certain check which
is that the kings are subject to the
moral law which is eternal
and obviously it's the highest power in
the world they're subject
to god they can't just do whatever they
want but these
liberals these leftists won't even
acknowledge that they won't even be
checked
by that this gets to something at the
heart of the
republican and conservative tradition
which is busting up
big unchecked power cruz gets it
lee gets it hawley gets it why don't the
rest of those guys in washington get it
because that is the future of the gop
get on board or get
run over we are going to take these
things much more seriously than in the
past
and we're going to break up those
ossified ridiculous slogans
that pretend that woke billionaires in
silicon valley
ought to do whatever they want including
undermine our country no i don't think
so buddy that seems kind of like a
public sphere
to me too no matter how much you want to
pretend it's private speaking of the
future of the gop
talk about a big tent party caitlyn
jenner
is seriously considering running for
governor
of california according to reports we
had mentioned this about a week ago
that there was a rumor i didn't know if
it was real or not well according to
politico caitlyn has hired up ryan irwin
who's a former top california gop
official had roles on romney and jeb
bush's presidential campaigns
hired up harmeet dillon a republican
national committee
member and a san francisco attorney
hiring up carolyn wren long time gop
fundraiser and brad parskal who was the
ousted
campaign manager for trump 2020. that
seems a little bit more serious now
how should one think about this
obviously
caitlyn is quite mistaken about a
fundamental aspect of human nature
namely that
men can't be women and women can't be
men though
his views are a little more nuanced on
this but he gets that
pretty wrong however
however politics is pretty strange we
vote for the
most right viable candidate to use
buckley's term
and i'm not convinced that caitlyn's
views even on transgenderism
are further left than governor pretty
boy
then nussolini up there i suspect new
cellini probably has further left views
than caitlyn jenner last i checked i
don't think caitlyn jenner supports
pumping
little kids full of hormones cross-sex
hormones
could be wrong about that but i don't
think so and on a whole host of issues
caitlyn
more conservative now there may be other
people who get into the race so i think
we should hold off before we start
waving the caitlyn jenner signs and
obviously there comes a point when the
party becomes so broad
that you've undermined your own
principles if you if you're
really going to exalt this idea that a
man can become a woman that that might
be too
too harmful to the republican party
broadly and you can't do it
but it would seem that caitlyn is
serious about
about running for governor we've
seen stranger things in california
before and if he does want to do that
he's got to get serious about
gop voters maybe california is ready to
turn i don't know
i always assumed that newsom gets
recalled but then he survives the recall
because there's too many democrats in
the state because they've been flooding
the state with illegal immigrants for a
long time
but maybe california is ready to turn i
don't know garcetti just went to opening
day at dodger stadium
he was there with a few other people
eric garcetti is the mayor of los
angeles
possibly the single worst mayor in the
country he might be worse
than bolshevik bill de blasio in new
york well when he went out there to
dodger stadium
that guy got booed please join me in
welcoming los angeles mayor
eric garcetti l.a city council member
gil cedille
hall of fame broadcaster jaime hadin
dodger owner billie jean king and dodger
owner
irvin magic johnson
wow so you see they're very clever here
because they have five big people
on stage and four of them seem fairly
popular so
you they they get the applause at the
end the first guy mentioned though is
garcetti and i think they know that
garcetti is going to get booed and you
can hear it
eric garcetti boo and then all the other
guys magic johnson or whatever yay we
like we like magic johnson
right but they don't like garcetti maybe
this means
that california has had enough the
pendulum takes a long time for that
pendulum to swing
perhaps it is beginning to swing back
how about at the national level
there are a lot of people who could run
for president 2024 it looks like
ron desantis wants to run i think he's
all but all but ready to dye his hair
blonde
and run in the trump lane and he's doing
an excellent job down in florida
i have said on the show before i've
encouraged senator cruz
to run for president i as i've just said
in this show i think he sees
sees where the republican party is going
and he's helping lead on it hawley seems
like he wants to run for president
nikki haley seems like she wants to run
for president
and nikki haley she got a lot of flack
recently because she seemed to
to turn against president trump well who
knows i mean it was she was quoted in a
politico article so
you take politico with a grain of salt
but
nikki haley is quite clear now she says
no
trump trump is the leader of the party
and if president trump decides to run
in 2024 then i will
not run that is a signal from
former governor former ambassador haley
that
the the old bush republicans the bushes
the old squishy republicans
they much to their chagrin are not
taking back the party
we are not going to be moving in that
squishy direction the future of the gop
if it is to have a future is to become
more conservative ben will be discussing
not just the direction of national
politics but also local politics are we
going to abolish the police
go check that out out on his show also
be sure to check out
the candice owen show it's already
episode five you know we can't get
enough of candace and her new show
what's the show called
it's called candace if you have not
checked it out yet
what are you waiting for she is a
fearless conservative leader
hosting this lively series of guests
each week for a panel discussion
interviews and her signature cancel
corner this week
she'll be hosting comedian and podcaster
adam corolla
tune in because you do not want to miss
their conversation the show streams on
fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
at dailywire.com you can get the audio
podcast canvas on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcasts if
you need some candace owens in your feed
look no further head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify and subscribe today
and be sure to leave a five star review
if you like what you hear we'll be right
back with a lot more
nikki haley is a good
bellwether on on where the gop is headed
because she has had support among the
moderate wing of the party before
but she's also had a lot of support
among trump supporters
and she lost a little bit of that
support when a political article came
out and she seemed to dispute that
political article
so and who knows you know the media the
media have lied before so
who knows in any case she was just asked
would you run
if trump runs in 2024 here's her answer
he still has a lot of popularity if he
runs again in 2024 will you support him
yes if he decides that he's going to run
would that preclude any sort of run that
you would possibly make yourself
i would not run as president trump ran
and i would talk to him about it you
know that's something that we'll have a
conversation about at some point if
that decision is something that has to
be made but yeah i would absolutely i
had a great working relationship with
him i appreciated the way he let me do
my job
i thought we did some fantastically
great foreign policy
things together and look i just want to
keep building on what we accomplished
and not watching
when was the last time that you talked
to him
after the election before january 6th or
after
before january so notice here she
doesn't hesitate
and the cynical people who who already
don't like
ambassador haley they'll say oh you know
it's just opportunism well
i don't know i mean if it were if it
were just opportunism and she was trying
to really just
calculate exactly what the answer should
be don't you think she might have paused
a little bit she might have hesitated
well
i'd certainly talk to the president but
she doesn't hesitate so whatever the
impulse is
i think she's showing excellent judgment
here not just on
the trump of it all but on the direction
of the gop
she is recognizing what senator cruz is
recognizing
what josh hawley is recognizing what ron
desantis is recognizing
which is that the future of the gop is
going to be
in the conservative direction it's not
going to be oh let's
you know asa hutchinson says we need to
castrate kids because we got to broaden
the tent
we got to have a big broad party bring
new people in
the the impulse i think for the past 20
years
was to reduce conservatism down to
do whatever you want just do whatever
you want oh we're the party of
let big business run roughshod over our
culture we're the party of
mutilate your body mutilate children do
engage in
all manner of degeneracy just hey just
don't make me pay for it
you know the gop was the party of
permissiveness that was supposed to be
the conservative tradition it hasn't
conserved very much
it hasn't conserved the ladies restroom
and now i think what a lot of people are
waking up to
is that there is a difference between
liberty and licentiousness
there's a difference between our higher
will and our lower will
the clearest way to understand the
difference between our higher will and
our lower will
is when you go on a diet when you're on
a diet you get hungry
your lower will says feed me feed me
give me give me you know your appetites
down here
but your higher will says no i want to
lose weight i want to be more in control
of my body
and so you want your higher rational
will to dominate
because your rational will is the
intermediary between your lower base
appetites
and the divine will to which it is
turned
and you recognize as our founding
fathers did that you need to cultivate
that higher will if you want to have
true liberty
and if you get rid of all that and you
just give in to whatever desires however
disordered they are
that is simply going to be
licentiousness and it's going to totally
undermine liberty
you need to sometimes say no it's a
little counterintuitive in our day and
age but if you want to be more
free sometimes you have to say no this
is
an insight that i try to develop quite a
lot in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now
for pre-order so
nikki haley getting a lot of other
politicians getting this
harry reid on the democrat side of the
aisle harry reid former
senate majority leader for democrats
harry reid says look there's a big
radical agenda going on right now jim
acosta
on cnn is trying to get him to double
down yes yeah more radicalism put the
pedal to the metal
but harry reid is a clever politician
and he might see which way the political
winds are blowing
and he urges democrats hey be
careful what you do now you might not be
in power forever
i think something sort of uh
thought-provoking came out of the bible
administration this past week and it
didn't get a lot of
attention because there's so much going
on in the news he's now created a
commission to look at adding
seats to the supreme court other ideas
that some progressives are pushing for
they want to see the court's
conservative majority
be balanced where do you stand on that
do you think it's a good idea to add
seats to the supreme court
i think it's we should be very very
careful in doing so
i have no problem with the commission
but i think that the commission
is going to come back and disappoint a
lot of people because i think they're
going to come back and say
we should just kind of leave it alone i
think it would be
inappropriate this time after that long
history of that in the country
have term limits for judges uh i think
that we better be very very careful
in saying that we need to expand the
supreme court i think we're very very
very careful
i love jim acosta you can just see how
christ fallen he becomes by this answer
shortly thereafter he says okay well see
harry read by not the answer i was
looking for but
harry reid is not all of a sudden
worried about
the state of our country and coming
together in kumbaya i mean this is the
guy
who severely weakened the filibuster and
mitch mcconnell famously said to him
you all you're doing this today but
you're not going to be in power and
you're you're going to regret this
sooner than you think
say hello to my little friend he
he was right too because then the
republicans came into power and pushed
through a lot of things that they wanted
so harry reid always willing to go pedal
to the metal when he thinks he's got
political advantage
but i think here what he's seeing is
gosh there's a lot of discontent in this
country right now
over immigration over blm terrorists
burning the country to the ground
over pumping little kids full of
cross-sex hormones
this is the people are not totally on
board with the left's agenda the left
has attained cultural hegemony so
they're able to wield a lot of influence
even though they don't have
a ton of popularity in in terms of their
policies
but that's not going to last forever
eventually the people are going to say
no and he says
slow it down harry reid here
frankly is giving me more hope than any
of
the other politicians of either party
because
i think he's a pretty good bellwether
too there's actually
unlike a lot of the news recently i
think there's actually a fair bit of
reason to hope
you got the gop signaling that they get
that the future
needs to be more conservative for that
party and you're getting democrats
saying hold on gosh i maybe we're not as
confident as we're pretending
that we are speaking of urging caution
this news we mentioned it very briefly
yesterday
but it bears a little bit more fleshing
out
the fda and cdc are pausing
one of the covid vaccines the johnson
johnson vaccine here
is their here is their statement
we are recommending a pause in the use
of this vaccine
out of an abundance of caution as of
april 12th
6.8 million doses of the vaccine have
been administered in the us cdc
uh in the u.s rather the cdc and fda
reviewing data involving six reported
u.s cases of a rare but severe type of
blood clot
in individuals after receiving the
vaccine right now these adverse
events appear to be extremely rare okay
so they're pausing it now
i hate to say i told you so but i told
you so there are two big arguments here
and they don't cut neatly across party
lines there's some republicans
who are super into the vaccine some who
even seem to
support some kind of vaccine passport
and there are
some left wingers who maybe are a little
bit more skeptical of the vaccine so i
think here that broadly the two camps
you have people on one side saying come
on it's only six cases
the risk of blood clot from birth
control drugs from oral contraception is
much higher
no reason to pause it let's keep pumping
out that vaccine
then you have people on the other side
saying see we told you so the vaccine
isn't safe it was rushed through
nobody should take the vaccine and here
i am
right in the middle holding the same
position i've held from the beginning
which i think is being proven truer and
truer each day which is that
anything you do in politics and in your
personal
life is is going to involve some degree
of risk and
a great key to politics which none of
the rationalists on either side on the
left or on the right want to acknowledge
is prudence prudence is not just a
virtue broadly
it is specifically and especially a
conservative virtue
you weigh your risk if i were
extremely obese and 85 years old
i would very likely take that vaccine
because i would feel that i had some
risk
some serious risk of coronavirus if i am
a relatively healthy 30 year old then
i probably won't take the vaccine
because i don't think i'm at great risk
and by the way if god forbid if i get
the virus
if god forbid i have some terrible
adverse side effect
do not let them write articles about me
let's say virus skeptic
or vaccine skeptic has a terrible
adverse side effect or
adverse consequence of the virus don't
let them write those articles
because i am acknowledging i know that
there is a risk but there's a risk in
anything in life
and i'm just making a risk calculation
based on the numbers here
based on the data the science and i'm
recognizing that i have a greater risk
of getting in a car
and drive driving to work than i do from
the coronavirus as a relatively healthy
millennial doesn't mean i have zero risk
i'm just recognizing that all of life
has a risk
so it seems to me people ought to use
their prudence and their judgment
now president trump interestingly came
out and is very upset at the pause in
the vaccine he says
the biden administration did a terrible
disservice to people throughout the
world by allowing the fda and cdc to
call a pause in the use of the johnson
johnson vaccine
dr fauci on the other hand is saying um
i don't think it was pulling the trigger
too quickly to pause the vaccine
we are ruled by the science and not any
other consideration
first of all we are not ruled in this
country by the science at least we're
not supposed to be we are supposed to be
ruled by ourselves
within the confines of the constitution
using our higher reason
when the science capital s with a
trademark over the e
and its high priest its pontiff dr fauci
are not supposed to rule us
and the science seems to change day by
day by day
the science would not have been a great
guidepost in assessing your
risk from the virus or from the vaccine
the science told us don't wear masks
through the pontiff dr fauci then a few
weeks later the science told us you have
to wear masks
through the pontiff dr fauci then the
science told us there's no risk
whatsoever from the vaccine
then the science told us there is such a
risk that they're going to pause the
vaccine
and maybe they've said it's going to be
a short pause but then other people have
said it might be paused indefinitely
so the science quote unquote is not
going to guide you your prudence and
your higher
faculties of reason will there's even
descent among the left on this
not on the vaccine specifically but for
instance on the origin of the
coronavirus
the former cdc director uh robert
redfield we played this on the show a
couple weeks ago
he suspects in just his private opinion
but he suspects
that the virus had something to do with
the wuhan institute of virology which is
a mile away from where the virus was
allegedly discovered this seems
pretty reasonable to me the left has
insisted no absolutely not it had
nothing to do
with the wuhan institute that's racist
to say that it did it's just it's from
the wet markets in wuhan
you can't even call it the wuhan virus
how dare you say well dr sanjay gupta
on cnn is dissenting from his cnn
colleagues he says you know
there's a fair chance it came from that
institute he's an experienced virologist
he was also head of the cdc at the time
this was happening which means
that in addition to everything that we
know uh he had access to
raw data and raw intelligence uh that
was coming out of china
my point is that it's it's a much more
informed sort of thing for him to be
saying
than for you know anybody who may have
expertise in virology
because he has a lot more knowledge and
information that
he has that maybe he can't share but is
informing his opinion i must have asked
the question a dozen different ways
and i and i and i gave a lot of escape
hatches for him
to to really clarify well you know
it's anybody's guess whatever and he did
you know he hedged a little bit he
didn't come out and say
100 percent this this came from but he
really was quite adamant that this this
is the the origin of the virus
you know i mean there's reason to
suspect that this is the origin of the
virus i mean it's the only
it's a big virology lab right in wuhan
that happened to be studying bad
coronaviruses
just from an occam's razor standpoint
finding the simplest
explanation it would make sense also
keep in mind that 14 months now 15
months into this we still don't know for
certain what the origin
is bingo thank you thank you dr gupta
thank you for being maybe the only
person on cnn to exercise
any prudence reason
uh open-mindedness to
what is right before one's eyes yes that
does seem
like a very likely i'm not saying it's
the definite cause but it's a very
likely cause there is reason to suspect
that that was the origin of the virus
no two ways about it now that might not
be politically correct because
the biden administration and the left
and liberal establishment
wants to have a good relationship with
china including big corporate america
including the big sports leagues which
are selling out our country
and our principles to make an extra buck
over in
china but we should
be able to call it like we see it we
should be able to pursue
the truth and to pursue our national
interest that is a
principled virtuous stance and people on
the left and the right don't want to do
it but i think the future
if we're going to have a conservative
future it is going to be
just that recognizing that we do have a
national
interest here and we ought to pursue
truth not the delusions and fantasies of
the left
speaking of medical advice there was an
article in the washington examiner
which i i had to read because i think it
shows you
the divergence between the old
right-wing order and the new right-wing
order
this one i think is representative of
the old
kind of squishy wing of the right over
the past 20 years
the writer says headline he won't allow
over-the-counter birth control
but biden is pushing risky at-home
abortions
so to me when i read that headline i say
okay
so biden's baton 500 here you know that
allowing risky at home abortion's bad
but hey at least he won't allow
over-the-counter birth control but then
i find
in the article the author writes quote
an easy solution here would be to
deregulate oral contraceptives so that
uninsured women can acquire them over
the counter
reducing the pills list price over time
and reducing unplanned pregnancies among
a democratic
demographic least able to afford
children lucky for biden senate
republicans such as joni ernst of ohio
of iowa rather
among others are on board with this this
that's that's the opposite
of what we ought to do that is exactly
the wrong
conclusion why
why michael because you're a scold a
prude a theocrat
no why would we make it easier
even than it already is it's extremely
easy to access oral contraceptives why
would we make it easier
so that underage girls can get them that
would be one
that would be one consequence of
over-the-counter
oral contraceptives so that we can
further reduce our birth rate we already
have a dying population we already have
a very low birth weight
should we really do that so that we can
further
promote the hookup culture and the
culture of casual sex that has given
rise to the metoo movement and
claims of epidemic sexual assault on
campus around the country
because of that because it makes women
so much happier
because it makes families so much more
stable no
i don't it doesn't make any sense at all
i'm making a prudential judgment here
based on the actual circumstances
of the country i'm not making some
totally abstract rational argument
rationalist argument rather whereby the
only
the only principle in our politics is
maximizing individual autonomy
and individual liberty meaning our
basest passions
i'm just looking at the prudence of it
why would we do that that seems like it
would be
worse right sometimes
to have greater freedom you have to say
no there is this common thread have you
noticed this to liberal activism to
left-wing activism even
among the sort of libertarian or squishy
types on the right
they always seem to want fewer people
notice that they want legal abortion
in the name of women's rights they want
subsidized contraception
or much even easier access than we
already have to contraception
in the name of personal autonomy they
want euthanasia in the name of mercy
they want smaller families because of
climate change or overpopulation
completely made up
problem they want to pump little kids
full of hormones that will castrate them
in the name of transgender health so no
matter what
what the argument they always seem to
want fewer people isn't that weird
does that make you think huh what is the
what is the metaphysical aspect going on
what is that what is the
dare i say it spiritual
underpinning of all these policies that
seem to be so
anti-human we've got one of the more
ridiculous examples right now in
colorado
colorado might become the second state
to legalize
human composting and to allow human
remains to be composted after a person
passes away
love you grandma love you grandpa hey
love you
great aunt becky can't wait to put you
in my garden
can't wait to eat tomatoes that sprout
out of your liver or something no
gross that's bad and why is it bad why
is it bad
i understand the rationalist argument
for composting grandma
okay the rationalist argument is look
come on it's just you're just taking a
dirt nap
just turn into worm food anyway might as
well get some
heads of lettuce out of you why come on
we're all just stuff we're all just
matter right we're all gonna turn to
dust anyway right even
we are from dust we are and to dust we
shall return so why not just toss
someone in the backyard let the
let the wolves come and eat you or let
some
let some vegetables grow out of you
there is a natural revulsion that we
have at this
it's what the bioethicist leon cass
would call the wisdom of repugnance
it seems anti-human seems pretty
undignified this is
human dignity according to the libs it's
turning your grandma into mulch
let me ask you something if you're if
you're tempted to go along with the
colorado thing
if you were walking along the street
and you saw a dead body would you kick
it
would you spit on it would you
desecrate that body no i bet you
wouldn't
if you god forbid stumbled on
a member of your family dead you some
this has maybe happened to a number of
people
would you attack that blood would you
punch it
would you desecrate that body no you
wouldn't you just wouldn't do it
why not the rationalist in you would say
that's just a hunk of flesh
well the word desecrate tells you
everything because you recognize that
there is
something sort of sacred about
the human person there's some hint of
divinity there
that man is made in the image of god
that we treat
even a dead body with certain special
care that's why it's against the law to
desperate bodies
why is that because we recognize at
least on some gut level we used to
recognize in our whole culture
that we're not just meat puppets we're
not just
worm food we're not just flesh
are not just our fleshy desires our will
is not just our fleshy desires
we have spirit and soul too and we have
a higher
rational faculty and a higher rational
will
too when we need to treat humans as a
little bit more special
and we need to treat human society as
more than just
our appetites and our desires in the
economically
rational materialist self-interested
society we're more than that culture is
more than that
conservatism is more than just saving a
couple bucks
and letting people pursue whatever
disorder desires they have
well what is it what's more than that i
think it's pretty clear
that our traditions our rituals our
american way of life
our self-respect our dignity is what
we're aiming at here
and the conservatives who recognize that
are giving us an opportunity for a
future
here a future for conservatives and a
future for the country
and the ones who don't recognize that
are
only driving faster or slower off the
cliff on the way to decline
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show